the Joe Rogan experience if there are
aliens do you want to be here when they
make contact well I think they're making
contact whether we like it or not that's
what I think I think they're looking and
watching whether we like it or not
they're observing and I think if you
were an intelligent being from another
planet you would want to make sure that
the territorial monkeys don't blow each
other up and that's what we are we're
like this adolescent stage of evolution
where we still have all of our primal
territorial jungle instincts but yet we
also have this insane ability to harness
the atom we also have this ability to
send videos through space and we can
catch them on your phone and play it
back and forth we hardly hold energy in
these little rectangular devices that we
hold in our pocket Lee charge them and
you charge in them with [ __ ] nuclear
power that's you know nuclear power
plants are charging our phones and then
the phones go into our pockets and then
we're like real close you know we're
real close to a lot of this crazy
technological innovation and it keeps
getting more and more spectacular with
every passing generation and they're
probably watching they're probably
watching and waiting and trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] we're doing and
if you believe what they told Bob Lazar
that they were responsible for an
accelerated evolution wait wait wait
wait this come on too much information
one of the things they were saying whose
day when he was working for what does he
work for the Air Force was it the Air
Force that Lazar was working for
whatever whatever the government body
that was operating area s4 they gave him
a bunch of breakdowns on a lot of things
they do and what where they think they
got these crafts from and where the
crafts are one of them was from an
archaeological dig he said but they gave
him an explanation of what these aliens
are here for and what they're doing and
one of the things that they said and he
said I have no method of verifying
whether or not that's true or not but
that they had accelerated the evolution
of primitive primates so they had taken
primitive primates and they had done
something to them to change them from a
primitive being to what we have now in
Homo sapiens and that's it very quickly
if you really look at evolution the
difference between Australia
and Homo Sapien it's only a few hundred
thousand years which is insane if you if
you think of how much more advanced we
are than those lower hominids and
there's no other animal that's
experienced that kind of a leap the
human brain doubled in brain size over a
period of two million years we have no
idea how we have no idea what happened
is all speculation whether it's eating
meat controlling fire using tools
hunting increased access to protein
changing from herbivores to omnivores to
carnivores all these different theories
the throwing arm that's another theory
that humans figured out a way to use an
arm to throw and hit things and that
accelerated our problem-solving skills
there's a lot of theories we don't know
but Terence Mckenna had a theory called
the stoned ape theory he believed that
human beings were experimenting with
psilocybin mushrooms and it's psilocybin
mushrooms accelerated our evolution who
knows we don't know but one of the
things that they were telling was our
when he was working at s4
back-engineering this these crafts were
that human beings were the product of
accelerated evolution and that these
space beings and that there was more
than one there was more than one
civilization that was involved in this
these space beings had had some sort of
a hand in this running experiment that
is the evolution of man
[Applause]